all right this story is it's a hardship
from our last story but this is the
story's hilarious we have two videos one
is the video of Burger King commercial
and in this commercial they triggered
our they intended to trigger Google home
and Google home of course is the you
know in home whatever you everybody
knows would Google home is at this point
a part of the problem is is that the
commercial depended on Google doing a
search for Burger King and the search
put up results from Wikipedia people
trolled the absolute hell out of Burger
King by constantly changing what
Wikipedia said for the whopper so
anytime this commercial played it will
pull up something less than flattering
shall we say about Burger King and at
first I thought that Google was in on
this it seems like they had no insight
as to the fact that Burger King was
going to make an ad out of this yeah
their device and the fact that the
Google home would just use the Wikipedia
search as what it reported the whopper
to be yeah you know everyone knows you
can edit Wikipedia yeah exactly I mean
you can edit it now you have to use your
username and so everybody knows who made
the edits but on a trolling master level
this high I don't think you care that
people know that you were the one so
let's let's stop talking about it let's
watch the the commercial itself and then
let's watch some of the responses you're
watching a 15-second Burger King at
which is unfortunately not enough time
to explain all the fresh ingredients in
the whopper sandwich and I got an idea
okay Google what is the whopper burger
all right so that's supposed to trigger
and but because of the edits to
Wikipedia these are some of the results
they got according to Wikipedia the
whopper is a burger consisting of a
flame-grilled patty made with 100%
medium-sized child with no preservatives
or fillers topped with sliced tomatoes
onions lettuce cyanide pickles - ketchup
and mayonnaise served on a sesame-seed
bun' alright so this happened over and
over and over again
Burger King kept getting wind of it
happening and they tried to go into
Wikipedia to correct it as quickly as I
can could but as soon as they were
corrected someone will come back and
change it and so ultimately
they had to pull the ad I think just
given the quality of the whopper
sandwich those edits are not too wrong I
would say cyanide and ground-up children
maybe a bit too far
definitely not the best decision for
food I've eaten plenty of whoppers I
know you're a vegan so you you know you
you have that I I think the whopper is a
decent decent enough burger going to the
big burger if you're gonna eat a
fast-food burger I think the whopper is
probably one of your best options the
rest of it is just not even edible in my
opinion so you're gonna leave out the
cyanide in the ground no side of sidon
cyanide no side of ground pickle of
ground children actually but so you
you're right Google was not in on the
gag but ultimately Google changed their
algorithms to make it so that the come
the Google home could not be triggered
by this commercial or any commercial for
that matter and so this is how the story
ends go of Burger King gets masterfully
trolled and Google has to come in and
salvage this this ad campaign I guess it
was a clever idea but it went wrong so
easily right I mean yeah you can't blame
them for trying except you can yeah I
love it I mean I I mean it's it's it's
again it's master-level trolling and I'm
sorry burking yet to be on the recipient
end of it the receiving end of it but I
absolutely love it I think it's
brilliant and this is what happens this
is what the internet is made for Pat
this is what the internet is made for